mais le royaume uni tout comme les
autres pays sont donc très polarisée par
rapport au rôle de l'europe il frédéric
dans quelques jours ça risque de se
ressentir en tout cas pendant les
élections européennes
voilà donc des élections qui vont se
tenir sur quatre jours ça commence jeudi
ça se termine dimanche donc ça veut dire
que les pays membres ne votent pas tous
en même temps mais on va aller bien sûr
bien sûr attendre tout le monde à la fin
pour donner les résultats donc quelques
chiffres importants 28 états membres qui
vont donc passer par ce scrutin
il ya 427 millions d'électeurs qui vont
se prononcer tout ça pour élire 751
eurodéputés alors évidemment chaque pays
a son propre poids au niveau de la
proportion donc ça veut dire que si on
regarde ce graphique mais c'est
évidemment l'allemagne qui aura le plus
de députés avec 96 suivi de la france
l'italie le royaume uni et l'espagne
et ça va comme ça ainsi jusque
luxembourg et mal qui auront chacun 6
eurodéputés maintenant ce qui est très
particulier avec ces élections là c'est
qu'on ne vote pas pour un candidat ou
une candidate mais bien pour une liste
donc c'est à dire qu'elle est parti
politique qui constitue une liste avec
un nombre suffisant de candidats et bien
sûr parce que c'est un scrutin à la
proportionnelle
ce qui veut dire que plus une liste à
des votes plus évidemment elle peut
envoyer des candidats et donc des
députés à l'assemblée politiques de
strasbourg
une fois que ces candidats ont été élus
bella il faut faire un choix parce que
dans l'hémicycle il ya huit groupes qui
sont définies alors sa part évidemment
par exemple de l'extrême gauche là avec
par exemple la groupe la gauche unitaire
il ya les socialistes démocratiya les
verts au centre il ya par exemple les
libéraux-démocrates qui est le parti
populaire européen et plus on va vers la
droite mais plus on a des partis qui
sont conservateurs qui sont
eurosceptiques et anti-immigration si
jamais les candidats ne se reconnaissent
pas dans ces groupes là eh bien ils sont
alors des non-inscrits il y en a
actuellement 22 et si on regarde à la
dissolution du parlement la répartition
vous voyez on va de l'extrême gauche
jusqu'à l'extrême droite c'est
actuellement le parti populaire européen
qui a le plus grand nombre suivi des
socialistes et démocrates
et on pourrait croire que c'est pas le
cas mais en fait elles sont importantes
ces élections parce qu'elles touchent le
quotidien des électeurs
et effectivement céline parce que les
751 députés qui vont au parlement de
strasbourg
mais ils ont leur mot à dire d'abord ils
votent ils amende ils discutent des lois
qui touchent par exemple l'école de
l'écologie l'environnement la santé ou
encore l'immigration donc c'est très
important pour les européens or quand on
regarde ils vont aussi le budget de
l'union européenne
or quand on regarde le taux de
participation depuis la première
élection européenne c'est-à-dire en 1979
de regarder la tendance est évidente
on a un déclin continu de 63% on est
passé à 42 et il n'y a rien qui laisse
penser que c'est un une tendance qui va
s'inverser avec le vote dans les
prochains jours merci pour ce petit
cours 101 des règles européennes très
utile merci flec